the promise of AI has always been to
make lives better and do things that
we're doing now on our own in a much
more efficient in much more powerful way
but to do that AI need to learn and to
learn it needs information and one of
the best sources of information we have
on the world and how it works is it in
the video cameras or EMA a phenomenal
amount of video is generated every year
and it's not just the hundreds of
millions of cameras all around us it's
the billions of cell phones we also put
our pockets prism is a cloud software
company that connects the cameras that
already exists in the marketplace and
analyzes that video in a way no human
can it slices and dices the video and
put that into our data structure so it's
search-form available to customers
Microsoft is a big part of the smarts
that helped the indexing and
understanding a video happen to use
prism all you have to do is pull out
your phone and type in what it is you're
looking for and where and prism will
find it the value comes from unlocking
the hidden information and video and
that can be just as valuable for a
factory or construction site or hospital
as it is for retail store prism also
takes that video feed and turns it into
a stream of information that can be used
to let that business for a better
Microsoft's computer vision API can
understand different kinds of objects
text other types information
merchandisers might use us to look into
their stores around the world or people
in retail operations might use us to
build a dashboard of important metrics
places like hospitals or health care
facilities can use prism to understand
where their doctors are so they can more
quickly connect those doctors with
patients in verticals like industrial or
construction prism can be used to help
track really important critical
machinery if you're on a construction
site and you wanted to be notified when
the cement mixer
five you can use AI to do that prism
brings a really unique set of content
into the world of AI and machine
learning in Microsoft bring some of the
best technology and people in the world
to help understand that conflict it's an
exciting time and the coolest thing
about it is we're just getting started
[Music]